something you can do absolutely for free
is join the discussion at the david
pakman show subreddit davidpakman.com
slash reddit something like uh i don't
know it's it's gotta be close to 30
000 of our viewers and listeners now
subscribed to the subreddit
a few interesting posts i spotted this
morning that i want to point out to you
our friend the eggman showed up he is on
the subreddit
and he says my dream ticket and
nightmare ticket
in 2024 al franken anthony weiner
is the progressive d dream team sexual
allegations aside
mike pence mike pillow 2024
is the nightmare that ruins sleep the
eggman of course signing off with his uh
typical
shalom uh yeah i am i'm not so sure
about frank and weiner
frank and weiner may be a tough sell i
think strategically doesn't mean al
franken's not a brilliant guy
doesn't mean anthony weiner uh is not a
excellent
debater and all that i think that's a
tough one um
and as far as the right goes my money
would be
if you give me an even money bet is the
2024 ticket
mike pence and mike pillow mike lindell
of course
i say it is not i'm taking the no bet on
that one but interesting to hear from
the eggman there
user bread tube forever posted what's
tulsi gabbard
up to you might be asking it turns out
tulsi was on fox news comparing cancel
culture
to isis and al qaeda in a fox news
interview
yes i don't think tulsi is doing
anything
that's surprising to anyone that
has been uh paying attention to tulsi
gabbard
for some time and then user
smm 97 has a tip for listening to the
david pakman show
pro life tip listen to the david pakman
show on
1.3 x speed concentrated pacman
saying increasing the playback speed br
brings a bit more energy to the
broadcast
more info in less time sometimes i even
go for 1.5 to 1.66 speed
give it a shot and try it out for
yourself and some people reporting
in the comments that they actually
listen to the show on 2x speed you know
i've talked with other podcasters about
whether
we find it offensive that people speed
us up to listen to the episodes more
quickly i really don't i mean
there for some people listening to shows
is something you do
sort of like for pleasure some people
can you imagine some people find it
relaxing i know some people fall asleep
to the sound of my voice because it's so
uh to some uh uh uh soperific
but um i i don't if you're just trying
to get
information you have a bunch of podcasts
you're listening to i take no offense to
people listening more quickly
i sometimes do that with certain types
of content but if you're just
listening for pleasure rather than to
cram like for an exam
then maybe you listen at 1x and i know
sometimes i
i don't speak that quickly um
and so i take no offense whatsoever
listen at any speed that you want
just be aware that the show will start
sounding like ben shapiro's show
at about 2x and that may be triggering
to some people
join the discussion join the subreddit
it's free at davidpakman.com
reddit one of our sponsors purevpn
is giving you 47 off a one-year plan
which comes out to less than
six bucks a month purevpn makes you
anonymous online
and you can trust them they're the only
vpn with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
off a one year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman